This is a production of Cornell University
Welcome to Cornell University's online Cornell
garden-based learning courses. We are thrilled
about your interest in one or more of our
courses. Please take a few moments to watch
this video which outlines several important
details. These courses are designed for adult
learners who wish to expand their knowledge of
the topic often for their own enrichment. As with
most online or autonomous learning situations
students typically get out what they put into
the course. The courses are non-accredited and are
designed for non-matriculated students. So you do
not have to be enrolled at Cornell University and
the course does not count towards college credit.
We find that the most successful students are
those who are intrinsically motivated to complete
readings and assignments to devote considerable
time to coursework and to communicate with your
classmates freely and often in an effort to
get the most from this course. We welcome
participants from around the world and find that
international students at a unique perspective
to the course environment. Each course is catered
toward a different skill level. Please review the
course syllabus for the course you are interested
in to learn about the target audience for that
specific course. For example, Organic Gardening
is designed for beginners while Botanical
Illustration 3 - Advanced Techniques is designed
for those with greater mastery of the subject
area. The courses are fully online and students
should have a basic knowledge of how to use a
computer and have an openness around learning the
technology. It is not necessary to have previous
experience with taking online courses. Students
will have access to the course interface for the
time frame of the course. Much like a traditional
classroom in which once you leave the room and
the course is over when this course is finished
you are responsible for keeping any records you
wish since the course is cleared or reset for the
next group of participants. Students who complete
all assignments will receive a certificate of
completion at the conclusion of the course.
Though specific supplies will vary for each course
students must have a computer with high-speed
access. Some courses also require a device for
scanning particular assignment submissions.
Please listen carefully to our refund policy.
If you choose to withdraw any time prior to the
end of the introductory period before the start
of Lesson One you can receive a refund MINUS a
one hundred and fifty dollar processing fee.
This fee applies to each course dropped. Once
week one has begun we are unable to provide you
with a refund. Given that this course demands
a significant amount of time, attention,
and energy over an extended period of time,
it is important to take steps in advance of the
program to ensure that you have the necessary
support structures in place. The estimated time
commitment varies for each online course. Please
review the course syllabus for the course you are
interested in to learn about the estimated hours
per week. Most courses are six to eight weeks and
offer a blend of online and hands-on learning.
Each week's lessons will contain a combination
of selected readings, activities to carry out
at home, reflective writing, student discussion
forum prompts, and optional additional readings,
activities and resources. Students submit
their weekly assignments before the stated
deadline and the instructor provides timely
feedback. Though the class is not live,
participants are expected to keep up with the
weekly assignments and discussions. Because the
weekly topics build on each other, skipping a
topic one week will cause some confusion. It is
a requirement to engage in at least a full page
of reflective writing weekly. While some students
initially balk at this, most appreciate how with
time the reflection helps to deepen their course
experience. As John Dewey so famously said,
"We do not just learn from our experience.
But we learn from reflecting on it." The student
discussion forum is a way to share resources and
get to know one another. Although sharing your
work with others is not required, some students
also appreciate the chance to offer their work
for celebration and feedback from others. Open
dialog is encouraged between the instructor and
students. Students are encouraged to contact their
course instructor with any questions. Some courses
have an introductory period before the beginning
of week one. This is a time for students to gain
access, become familiar with the course interface,
and practice doing a few simple tasks -- such as
posting an introduction in the student discussion
forum. Successful students take time during the
introductory period to carefully read all course
materials and become familiar with the nuances of
the course offering. If you are taking drawing,
watercolor, or the advanced techniques botanical
illustration course, it is much better to
spend a shorter period of time each day on your
assignments then to power through an occasionally
four or five hour chunks of time. You will want
to devote at least 12 to 15 hours per week,
and with increasing hours you will gain more
proficiency. You'll grow much more in scale
with more sessions and in addition stay on top of
the assignments. Though the assignments are not
difficult -- in fact they can be enjoyable
and relaxing -- there are many of them. It
is important to keep your expectations modest.
These are just six-week courses. And remember the
10,000-hours rule of thumb: It takes a long time
to gain mastery. If you have additional questions,
please review our frequently asked questions
page. If you are unable to find an answer there,
then please email the relevant point of
contact for the course in question. Thank
you for watching this video and we hope
to see you in one of our future course
offerings. This has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell edu